hey guys it's Justine and today we have
the brand new M2 Max MacBook Pro yeah I
I know I can't believe it either but
it's here
here it is oh my goodness beautiful
beautiful MacBook
now obviously the design of this is very
similar to the previous version so if
you were to just look at this you would
have no idea that it is the brand new M2
Pro Max now one of the differences
though in the new version if you do get
the space gray is they do color match
the magsafe adapter I'm actually way
more excited than this than you can even
understand the Brady cable is also a
little bit darker
if you were to get the silver one I feel
like there was a probably a more elegant
way to open this but I have ruined all
of Apple's hard engineering work and
packaging I'm so sorry it's not right
okay here we go let's check out that
color match
look at that
beautiful let's see what else we have in
here we gotta take a look at the
stickers oh and they're the darker
colored ones
also got our charging brick
I always like getting the extension
cable for these so it's much longer
super easy you just pop that right off
pop in the extension and you are set the
first open here we go
oh no I need to see the Apple logo
the reveal
it's one of the biggest upgrades though
other than obviously having the M2 Max
or the M2 Pro chip you can upgrade these
to 96 gigs of ram in a laptop that is
basically well I don't it's not fanless
it does have fans the things that I have
put my previous M1 Max MacBook Pro
through I've maybe heard the fans twice
over the last year and that's probably
because I had it sitting on my lap in
bed over top of a heavy blanket and
that's what made the fans go on like
when I say that I'm impressed with the
MacBook Pro like I can't even honestly
put into words what an incredible device
these have all been since they've
upgraded to the Apple silicon the
difference that it has made in
performance and heating and Battery
I don't know it's just it's literally a
perfect machine like I don't have
anything to complain about now the other
thing is these do come in two different
size models you can get a 16 inch or the
14 inch so for me personally I did order
the completely maxed out 16 inch which
is it's pretty aggressive but having
that eight terabyte solid state drive
for editing and being able to take
things on the go and not have to have an
external drive has been actually quite
life-changing so let's set this up and
we can dive into more about what's new
so many beautiful pink cables as a
reminder you guys can get these at pink
ijustinecables.com I'm a little biased
it is my favorite color but let me tell
you what there were no high quality
Thunderbolt 4 cables that I could find
in the color pink well guess what
problem solved
foreign
MacBook Pro now you can choose from the
M2 Pro and the M2 Max in the 14 and 16
inch configurations the 14 inch starts
at 19.99 and the 16 starts at 24.99 with
the M2 Pro it comes with a 10 or 12 core
CPU and a 16 or 19 core GPU and you can
have up to 32 gigs of memory now with
the M2 Max it has up to a 38 core GPU
and it maxes out at 96 gigs of memory
and with up to 8 terabytes of storage
the design looks very similar to the
previous MacBook Pro it has an SD card
slot three Thunderbolt 4 ports Wi-Fi 6E
HDMI now supports output of up to 8K and
of course it has the magsafe 3 charging
you can get up to 18 hours of video
playback and 12 hours of wireless web
browsing on the 14 while the 16 has the
longest battery life ever in a Mac with
up to 22 hours of video playback and 15
hours of wireless web browsing so we're
all set up now I'm gonna pop into the
project that I've been working on the
video that you're watching right now now
I am editing this off of an external
drive this MacBook specifically has a
two terabyte solid state drive which is
not quite big enough for my needs but if
you are looking to cut costs that is one
of the places that you can start because
you can always use external drives and
be able to make up for the lack of
storage that you don't have this is all
8K
this is a multi-cam timeline so when we
hop into here we have two cameras all 8K
from the A1 we also have all of this
footage here which is all s-log I mean
we're just editing like this is 1080p
footage it is so smooth it's like look
at this we're in we're in let's layer
something on top of that three streams
of AK let's just buy another one on Just
for for the heck of it shall we four
streams of 8K running perfectly smooth
can we go for a fourth
fifth I am not good at counting yeah
it's fine okay we got a little bit of
okay well it picked back up okay well
now that rendered in the timeline it's
working pretty smooth so these are just
straight out of the Sony camera these
are not prores literally directly off of
the card onto the drive into the
computer and it's running it's sold one
how many do we have here one two three
four five six seven what if we did one
of these numbers
I'm just going to move a bunch of 8K
stuff around our timeline
[Music]
okay I think we finally finally got a
spinning Beach ball thank you please
okay no you're still playing but you're
still playing so I do feel like as soon
as this kind of renders out in the
timeline it's probably gonna play so I'm
now exporting this project from Final
Cut in compressor and while that's
happening I'm also going to test out
Lightroom so Lightroom is very processor
intensive okay so now we're gonna import
some photos here oh my gosh this was
just the absolute best view in the
entire world this place is called nihi
it's in Zumba in Indonesia
took like 38 hours of travel to get
there
like we're just scrolling through the
photos
super fast while we're also exporting oh
it's already finished okay that only
took four minutes
there it is
[Music]
brand new
I mean that's art right there
look at that let's see if this will run
now
oh my gosh it's running
perfect it's running perfectly smooth
since this is rendered in the timeline
look at this
I cannot wait to edit videos this year
I'm so excited so as you can see this is
pretty fast
I mean these are all every single one of
these are all Raw photos
now we've tested off no cut which I'm
very proficient with I have always
wanted to learn DaVinci Resolve and I
have not yet I just need to take the
leap pop in spend a couple of days and
get familiar with it but I have it some
said my friend Nathan is coming over
he's gonna help me out and give me a
demo and show me how to do some coloring
and see if we can push this thing to its
limits so I'm here with my friend Nathan
I'm Nathan you're like my resident of Da
Vinci colorist thank you very much and
I'm so excited that you're here because
you were actually here for the previous
version of this MacBook yeah so you're
back again so this is the M2 Max this is
the 12 core CPU 38 core GPU we have 64
gigs of RAM and we have two terabyte
solid state drive I'm excited that
you're here because I also have
something that I have wanted to try for
the past couple of years I've really
wanted to get into Da Vinci and I
haven't really kind of fully immersed
myself yet okay hold on a second when I
get into hobbies and things what do you
have I really get into them okay great
so we're going from zero yeah to 60.
this is perfect as fast as my Tesla
plaid okay calm down okay so this is the
black magic design micro panel it's
heavy I don't want to hit you in the
head
you've never used this before never used
it this is gonna be a lot of fun but
today is the day we've also got our pink
iJustine cables so we are decking this
out okay so I've got some AK footage
we've shot in s-log and then there's
some that is just regular let's do s-log
when I edit things in Final Cut I just
drag them can I just drag that stuff
into there try it let's learn
uh so we're mirroring so on here is
really small it's really what does this
say let's just do this stack a whole
bunch of Clips on top of each other we
can also try that okay so not magnetic
we're not we don't have magnetic
timeline are you doing Final Cut Pro
keystrokes right now no they're not
working I was trying we're gonna switch
this to Final Cut
but this isn't a da Vinci video no this
is a MacBook Pro M2 awesomeness video
yeah so we want to get color in here so
we've got a couple layers here so here
we go this is four layers
and now five layers Okay cool so it's
five layers but it's five layers of
uncorrected footage so now let's throw
some crazy color correction on all of
these layers okay we're creating a new
node every time you option s you create
a new serial node okay the serial nodes
think of them like layers in Photoshop
so let's go to where it says input color
space and let's change that so there we
go Sony yeah let's use cine so then
we're going to change our input gamma I
saved my first node for noise reduction
and I do my primary grade in my middle
note all right so how do we what do we
do first let's pick something okay I
would like to make it warmer let's not
do that with color temperature
right you're only actually changing a
very small portion of the color spectrum
when you do that brightness is clockwise
darkness and it's Shadows mid-tones
highlights up left you're going towards
warmer colors
I'm having a moment like this is too
much no this is awesome it's so much fun
it's so cool I think it's great I'm so
hyped right now this is so freaking fun
so like oh my gosh this is great
oh I'm having a lovely time so now let's
just copy and paste this look for
starters I suppose you could bring your
lift down a skosh if you wanted to and
the highlights this is the Highlight so
that's gonna take the top portion we all
know I love my saturation yeah this
makes me so happy okay cool let's add
some noise reduction so can you see a
difference when I
that's off
that's on yeah it looks like there's a
little you can definitely see like a
little glowy right yeah okay so it's 8K
it's still playing back at 12 frames per
second with crazy noise reduction and
color correction
wow the MacBook is still amazing
previous generation MacBooks I couldn't
never you'd never dream of 8K how many
stacks we have six yeah that's crazy six
8K 422 10 bit files stacked on top of
each other all playing simultaneously
with both spatial and temporal noise
reduction cranked to high heaven this is
insane
I mean it's still it's it's still
playing through what are they gonna do
next year I don't know an M3 with 128
gigs of RAM I don't know let's just live
in the now and enjoy this moment yeah
it's Namaste also
also
there's no fans on at all what like this
there's yeah I mean what that fan that
you hear is from that light
do you hear anything no
okay oh well I think I hear something
you turn on the old Intel Max and it
sounds like a spaceship is taking off
I'm not surprised and even the battery
life I mean like you've been traveling
around the world doing all kinds of
crazy shoots and not having to worry
about am I going to be able to plug this
in on a plane like I know that even with
an external drive I'm gonna be set for
you know four hours so what do we have
here so here's my final cut project this
is basically everything that we shot for
the unboxing of this computer that we're
working on right now so I mean this is
all 8K this is in a multicam clip so
when we hop inside here we've got both
of the clips and then this is three
streams I mean it is running
it's it's running so smooth
I mean the thing's the same I know and
when I popped all of the stuff into the
timeline I mean there was a little bit
of rendering but once all of this like
did its thing like we are running but
how long did it take for it to render I
don't know as we were shooting b-roll it
was done I was we were editing and it
was just going we're so happy blown away
once again and I think the good thing
too is now we're kind of at a place the
Apple silicon has been out for a couple
of years so a lot of those early bugs
are worked out yeah like a lot of the
peripherals weren't working and things
like that and a lot of the apps are
updated so like now is the time like you
can just jump in and pretty much do
whatever you need to do that's a really
good point yeah I have figured out I've
got all those updates all the software
that I use everything is now am chip
compatible so yeah now it's just like
unlocking the full potential of all of
those plugins I gotta go I gotta go edit
okay let's do some editing I'll let you
edit yeah I'll leave yeah okay I'll see
you soon okay I'll see you I'll see you
in the M3 next year we'll be back in a
year bye everybody
[Music]
foreign
so this entire video has been shot on
the Sony A1 and we're shooting it all in
8k and I even exported it in 8k and
uploaded to YouTube and AK now shooting
an AK might seem a little bit like
Overkill because most of the videos I do
export and upload 4K but what's really
amazing about this is I'm able to crop
in and not lose hardly any of the
quality at all in the video and as you
guys know if you've watched any of my
videos I love punching in for effect
even if we don't export an AK having
that extra quality really does make a
huge difference the other reason that I
wanted to shoot this in such high
quality is this upgraded HDMI port does
also support 8K output
[Music]
thank you guys so much for watching this
video I am looking forward to doing some
follow-up videos on this but honestly
like my follow-up video I already know
what I'm gonna say I'm gonna be like wow
it's incredible it's so fast I can't
believe how my workflow has already
improved even over the Speedy incredible
fast M1 like it just I don't know what
else to say it's an amazing device Apple
silicon has honestly changed the game
for creators for basically anybody who
is doing anything on their computer even
if you're just doing basic tasks it
makes everything so fast you don't ever
have to hear the fans and it's just
I'm hyped if you can't tell I'll see you
guys in my next video if you haven't
already please subscribe hit the Bell to
be notified when I post new videos and
leave me some comments below if there's
anything that you'd like to see me test
out because honestly I kind of just keep
doing the same things that I do every
single day but if you'd like to see
something specific please leave it in
the comments and hopefully we can make a
video about it I'm gonna start working
on the video that you just watched see
you later
[Music]